how do you instill the journalistic
practices that you
want with your employees yeah so we
don't do that type of Guta catch you
journalism but having said that would
you push back if you felt like there was
here here's an example you know that
girl who's blown up Bobby alof yes so we
had her on BFFs and um oh yeah you
started drama with the yes so we we um
we asked her uh did she like did she
sleep with Drake yeah and she answered
no this was a text so we had her on the
show The Drake stuff broke after but
since I knew her I texted her I'm like
uh hey I'm hearing you slept with Drake
and you got a divorced is that true kind
of joking like she is she's like off the
Record um no not true and something else
we retold this story on BFFs the next
week in our editors edit it and made it
appear like she was about to confirm
something salacious and it went Uber
viral I went ballistic on my social team
I don't want clicks I I I don't don't
know Dave I don't know no I don't
because you know what that clip was
going to do but I did do it but even
before no even before it became a big
story I had already ripped AP when she
says off the Record if you talk about
this off the record conversation then
you know no no it isn't Because the
actual no here it isn't Because the
actual clip it was all together so when
we were filming I she she said off the
Record haha no it's not true I said
here's a response haha off the records
not true I said it all together they cut
me like the clip cut me his point would
be and I I'm a fan but I have to say
this his point would be if she says off
the Record it's off the Record no I
disagree if she says off the Record no
it's not true that's a misogynist would
say that if she says Mischief would
definitely say something like that if
she says you machinist no it's off the
Record if she says uh off the Record no
it's not true together those two don't
mean anything if she said off the Record
yeah I slept with them I never would
brought it up oh oh oh she's being
sarcastic yes off the Record no it's not
true correct like off the Record yeah
it's true don't mention it you you don't
have to have something off the Record if
it never happens right exactly she wants
that lie to be out or that rumor to be
out there because it's clearly didn't
because she because she didn't address
the no no no she you got understand
different thing she what Al saying is
she would like people to think it might
have happened she definitely didn't she
went crazy
ah but I but I understand I understand
like the sarcasm here it's like if uh if
I'm like off the Record never had sex
with Paris Hilton you're like you don't
need to tell me that it was like she
didn't say [__] it was like I I I was
like did you sleep with Drake and your
uh marriage is ruined she's like off the
Record no like okay that's one more time
push back I'm going to dunk on you but
go come mind I'm 57 I've been dunked on
off the Record it's you're kind of
interpreting the tone of it through a
text message of this being sarcastic so
but no it was an interview
no she said off the Record no it's not
true that's right you read it back in
the video now you have kind of
interpreted the tone as being sarcastic
do you did you know that it was
beforehand no mean like you here's my
point you don't have to say off the
Record no I didn't sleep with
Drake but she said it to be joking can
you just tell me something right now off
the can you just tell me off the off the
Record how do you feel about Travis Kel
big fan but
that off the Record I've never committed
murder like that like it off the Record
yeah now if you wanted people to think
that you were a
murderer if I wanted people to think
you're a rapper that's a gangster rapper
and you want them to think that you're
dangerous and violent and you go yo off
the record I never even held a gun that
would be bad to put out there in the
world so if we're assuming that Bobby
wanted this is interesting if we're
assuming that Bobby wanted people to
think maybe something happened now it
was exposed that nothing happened and
it's the opposite drama because but she
still didn't want that to be out there
because now she has to clarify that she
never slept with him and now that can't
be out there in The Ether which might
have been you guys are going
down like a rabbit Journal but the fact
of the matter is this what real
journalist we got to get to the bottom
the fact of the matter is she was mad
that it's spiraled a rumor that they
they actually [__] and then did they
then there was like a I don't know what
happened then now they got a [__] no
well now they don't even follow each
other something happened with
them what happened what happened what do
you think happened that's what that's
what that's what promp something that's
what prompted he
said something happened I
know some weird [__] over there we got
to get to the for sake of clarity the
way this went down is they did the
interview together it went crazy viral
know do you do you little man
the way the way it [__] happen get
him the Ecstasy get him the Ecstasy
right now get him on to the concert they
unfollowed each other then I text like
the internet saying you guys [__] and
ruin B off the Record no to say off the
Record no together is a nothing comment
when you take out what is she saying
they played it in a a [__] clickbait
way that's how it
[Laughter]
went I you just got to believe it you
just got to believe it you believe
it Dave I'm waiting for like [__]
King Kong Bundy to come
run back here like three onone [__]
handicap match of all the things that we
were going to talk about today never
think it was Bobby Al
interview okay so so here's so you put
out a statement where your team put out
a statement which seemed kind of like
you put it out what the uh written
statement that was posted was still on
Al off yeah no no this is uh when you
the Washington Post and you were talking
about journalistic integrity and all
that kind offf but that was you it was
great the team Port yeah team yeah yeah
yeah yeah okay what
is at what point not us cuz we're
grandfathered into to like thinking oh
the New York Times really matters The
Washington Post really M we're old
people that when we see something
printed on paper we're like this must be
the truth this is real I wonder if like
teenagers now they're growing up
constantly seeing the president
criticizing the news the left criticize
the news the right criticize the news
cuz keep in mind when we were growing up
it was The Daily Show saying everything
coming out from the right was a lie and
fake and now you see the right saying
hey look at mainstream media look how
much they are liars and F so this this
generation's coming up going everything
that we're seeing we should be skeptical
of do they start looking at the New York
Times and Washington Post and do they
just go do they never have like a baked
in Trust of it I don't think they do and
I think just the way people consume
media is so different that I don't even
know they grow up on that like I
literally grew up in a household the
times is Gossip like if something was
said in the times it was true same with
the Washington Post my dad I've said it
many times he's a liberal guy hated
Trump he has
begrudgingly come to grips with the fact
and I think it like hurts him to the
core like that the media slanted like he
like he knows now Washington Post like
if he picks it up it's going to be
negative to me in it it's a big change
it's a big change to like you know might
basically killed journalistic Integrity
is Craigslist cuz that's what's sunk in
newspapers they made so much money off
the classifi Craigslist people would
just put their [__] on there for free
newspapers started taking crazy hits
layoffs everywhere now they're trying to
take make money however they can I see
that's my question is whether it's just
always been that way and there's if
there's more media now to expose it in
like more like go go backwards I would
have had no voice to like fight what is
going on so you look at all these uh you
know incidents in throughout history
that got us into Wars like the Gulf of
thing that happened with Vietnam right
this fake thing doesn't happen no ship
sunk and all of a sudden we're in a war
right there was no podcast for some
people to go yo I don't think a boat
really got exploded where are the dead
Americans like does anybody have a
cousin that was over there didn't come
back like so now that there is you could
make the argument that back in the day
there was um Mutual benefit for
everybody being on the same side of what
maybe the I the military industrial
complex or whatever the [__] you want to
say whatever the government wanted to
push through but now the fact you have
all these other Independent Media
sources out here we don't look like
Looney bins conspiracy it's the same
with a lot of things like sports like
athletes now have their own vehicle to
like get their own perspective out
whether it's on Twitter or X whatever
you want to call it before it was
newspaper writers who would you know
dictate the perception of an athlete and
now they're starting their own podcast
exactly the uh the what's the the Ryan
Clark wants fire oh there's a bunch of
athlete podcast are great yeah pivot is
great even the Manning bro are great
many brother we have a pat B
podcast pat first of all ran is [__]
yep like I was watching all his battle
rap stuff before and then the two of
them together are fantastic and um yeah
that's one of the weird podcasts that I
can actually watch if it's through Zoom
like usually I can't do the the zoom
pods but but for now I can [__] with it
but uh but yeah it's like I guess now
we're in the age of we don't need
experts on the thing to talk about it we
can get it right from the source yeah H
so all that changes I I I tend to think
media's always been you know history is
written by the winners like that is for
the most part always been true yeah